et les traces de sang un peu partout ils
voient des morceaux de l'ombre de chair
accrochés sur les murs à ce moment là
lui confrère lui aurait expliqué
l'inimaginable
31 octobre 1998 Nice dans les
Alpes-Maritimes il est 8h15
le téléphone du commissariat central
retentit il s'agit d'une urgence
on soit un appel à au commissariat à
Nice il y a eu un braquage dans la poste
de la rue Joffre dans le centre-ville de
Nice les hommes de la BRB brigade de
répression du banditisme arrivée
immédiatement sur place
évidemment il gèle les lieux il récupère
les employés du bureau de poste le
guichetière les témoins qui ont été
victimes de de cette équipe sont
terrorisées lorsque les policiers
arrivent
selon les témoins tout s'est passé très
rapidement
les braqueurs sont entrés dans le bureau
de Poste et ont agi avec une violence
extrême
par terre l'arme sur la tête
l'un et cagoulé l'autre est grimé
postiche et il y a un troisième la ronde
qui lui est en véhicule relais à la
sortie pour arracher tout le monde après
le braquage
le montant du butin est maigre
2250 euros un paquet de cartes
téléphoniques a également été dérobé les
malfaiteurs n'ont laissé aucune
empreinte derrière eux et sont repartis
à bord d'une 106 blanche
mais ce qui intéresse nettement plus les
enquêteurs ce sont des tenues portées
par les braqueurs
[Musique]
les auteurs étaient vêtus de
tenue d'agents municipaux de la ville de
Nice ce détail n'a rien d'anodin car
dans la région de Nice plusieurs hold-up
ont été effectués avec ces mêmes tenues
les enquêteurs ont sans doute à faire à
la même équipe une hypothèse confortée
par une autre information
[Musique]
qui est aussi intéressant en fait c'est
cette voiture en fait qui attend puisque
un troisième homme reste là en attendant
que donc le braquage se fasse et cette
voiture c'est une Peugeot 106 Peugeot
106 elle apparaît sur d'autres braquages
les plaques sont différentes mais le
véhicule est le même donc ils arrivent
par tous ces éléments en réalité à réuni
par le mode opératoire
les mêmes la même équipe évidemment non
identifiés parce qu'il n'y a pas de
trace pas d'ADN pas d'empreinte digitale
personne ne les reconnaît évidemment
face à des braqueurs agressifs et armés
les enquêteurs se doivent de faire vite
seulement ils n'ont pour l'instant par
la moindre piste
anis les semaines passent et les
attaques continuent plus rien arrête les
braqueurs d'autres types d'établissement
sont même touchés les policiers d’abrb
remontent sur 13 à faire 13 vols à ma
armés d'agence bancaires d'agences
postale il y a même un bar PMU à
attribué à la même équipe donc de ces
trois individus ce lundi c'est la
voiture utilisée par les braqueurs la
fameuse 106 et rapidement retrouvée dans
les quartiers nord de Nice entièrement
calciné
par chance les plaques d'immatriculation
sont encore lisibles et révèlent une
chose elles ont été volées mais c'est un
nouveau témoignage qui va permettre à
l'enquête de faire un bon spectaculaire
en décembre 1998 les policiers entendent
la victime d'un des braquages elle
s'appelle Michel c'est la guistière et
cette femme dit avoir l'impression
d'avoir déjà vu l'un des malfaiteurs
de la poste de Cagnes-sur-Mer
elle
est
qu'en vrai qu'elle a elle a un
pressentiment elle elle a déjà entendu
cette voix et elle a déjà vu en fait les
traits de cette personne et elle se dit
effectivement ça ressemble à un client
qui est venu quelques jours plus tôt pas
pour les policiers l'un des braqueurs
est certainement venu repérer
l'emplacement des caméras et des caisses
avant de passer à l'action
le baba du braqueur
au moins d'aller une fois à l'intérieur
de l'agence bancaire pour voir pour voir
la configuration des lieux les braqueurs
viennent peut-être de commettre leur
première erreur il suffit alors aux
policiers de vérifier la liste des
clients passés par l'agence les jours
précédant le hold-up l'un d'entre eux a
peut-être un casier judiciaire en
vérifiant la liste quotidien les
enquêteurs tombent sur une personne qui
va les interpeller c'est un certain
Philippe Rousseau qui a déjà un lourd
passé judiciaire il a été condamné pour
agression et port d'armes illégal donc
ça ça met les enquêteurs sur une piste
quand même assez sérieuse
Philippe Rosso un ancien malfrat sorti
de prison il y a quelques mois sa photo
est aussitôt montrée au précieux témoin
ils vont sortir la photo de Philippe
Rosso la présenter à la guichetière en
lui demandant est-ce que vous
reconnaissez l'homme qui est venu
chercher du liquide chez vous
elle regarde attentivement la photo et
après une courte hésitation elle s'est
dit je crois bien que oui c'est je suis
pas formel à 100% allez je suis formé à
80%
pour les policiers voici une piste très
sérieuse il se renseigne alors sur ce
suspect il se rendent compte que ce
philipprosau qui a été condamné pour
port d'armes légales agression et qui
vient de sortir de prison il est
domicilié chez sa grand-mère à
Cagnes-sur-Mer
[Musique]
à deux pas justement de l'une des postes
attaquées par la bande
et les coïncidences ne s'arrêtent pas là
la 106 des braqueurs avait des plaques
d'immatriculation volée et pas n'importe
où
les plaques qui ont été utilisées lors
des braquages sont des plaques qui ont
été cambriolées récupérés dans des
quartiers très proches de chez sa
grand-mère et dans Cagnes-sur-Mer
exactement où est domicile et Philippe
Françoise à ce moment-là donc c'est vrai
qu'il a de fortes présomptions sur ce
personnage pour la première fois les
policiers ont un nom et un nom qui peut
coller parce que l'individu en question
Philippe Rosso est connu des services de
police il est connu pour des faits
graves du coup ils ont enfin fil à
dérouler un fil que les policiers vont
exploiter Philippe Rosso et mission
écoute et attentivement surveillé ces
complices se cachent sans doute parmi
ses fréquentations des fréquentations
plutôt radicales Philippe Rousseau fait
partie de l'extrême droite on va dire la
branche dure d'extrême droite c'est
quand même des gens qui sont pas du tout
modérés dans leur dans leurs idées
politiques dans leurs idéaux dans la
religion aussi et parmi ces
fréquentations l'une retient l'attention
des enquêteurs
un certain Luc Onfray sur les écoutes
téléphoniques comme lorsque on les filme
ou lorsqu'on les photographies et bien
on voit qu'ils sont régulièrement
ensemble qu'ils se voilent le week-end
qu'il passe des des soirées ensemble
bref qui sont toujours très complices le
confront 28 ans et lui aussi un militant
d'extrême droite et habite les quartiers
nord de Nice précisément là où a été
retrouvé la 106 utilisé par les
braqueurs la coïncidence est troublante
les hommes de la BRB tiennent peut-être
une partie du gang seulement sans preuve
impossible d'arrêter ni au frais ni
Rosso alors que les braquages continuent
5 en deux mois les téléphones des deux
hommes sont toujours sous-étroites
surveillance lors des surveillances
téléphoniques on ferait Philippe Rosso
ne font rien transparaître n'évoque pas
de braquage donc à partir de ce moment
là les policiers commencent à un peu
douter de leur enquête douter des
personnages qui ont été
identifiés et c'est vrai que s'installe
un certain doute dans l'enquête ça
patine un petit peu en fait mais bientôt
la chance va enfin sourire aux
enquêteurs
[Musique]
en février 1999 les policiers de Nice
interceptent une conversation capitale
les deux hommes ils parlent d'un futur
braquage à Reims en Champagne a Philippe
Rosso
appelle Luc confré et lui demande
d'aller braquer avec lui à Reims une
banque et un fast-food
même si lors de cette conversation Luc
confrère refuse la proposition de
Philippe Rosso la BRB désormais certaine
que les deux hommes font partie du gang
de braqueurs
cette révélation finalement pour les
enquêteurs c'est aussi une récompense
parce qu'ils se disent que après trois
mois d'effort il connaissent finalement
au moins deux hommes deux braqueurs
récurrents de la région les policiers
décident alors de tendre un piège à
Philippe Rosso ils iront le cueillir à
Reims en flagrant délit
13 février 1999 les policiers sont en
planque devant le fast food vers 23
heures le gang passe à l'action les
policiers les arêtes quelques minutes
plus tard dans un parking souterrain
Philippe Rosso est aussitôt placé en
garde à vue mais lors de son
interrogatoire son attitude surprend les
policiers c'est vrai
c'est assez étrange pour un braqueur qui
est quand même violent qui utilise des
armes qu'on pense chevronnés tout d'un
coup il se met
il passe aux aveux directement les
prosos très rapidement va reconnaître
les faits va reconnaître les faits une
première série de braquage une deuxième
série braquage au total ce sont 25
braquages que reconnaît Philippe Rosso
mais pour l'instant il reste muet au
sujet de ses complices
au même moment à Nice les policiers
arrêtent lui confrères
[Musique]
quand il est interpellé c'est à 5h du
matin son domicile on ferait il comprend
pas et il interpelle les policiers en
demandant mais pourquoi
allez seulement les hommes de la BRB
fouillent l'appartement et tombe sur un
véritable arsenal
on retrouve des revolvers des de la
dynamique tout un attirail pour pour
faire des braquages en fait en quelque
sorte
le confrères est immédiatement placé en
garde à vue
[Musique]
contenu de l'évidence des preuves de sa
culpabilité monsieur Onfray n'aura plus
d'autres choix que d'expliquer quel est
son rôle et comment ça s'est passé le
confrère reconnaît alors avoir participé
à 16 braquages Philippe Rosso lui après
10 heures de garde à vue complète ses
aveux
il balance son équipe lui confrère deux
autres individus et puis un certain
Michel renard et ce Michel renard n'est
pas n'importe qui pour Philippe Rousseau
comme il va l'expliquer aux enquêteurs
dis-moi je suis bien placé pour vous en
parler c'est en quelque sorte un peu mon
beau-père parce que je suis le petit ami
de sa belle-fille Alexandra Martins
aussitôt il précise que cet homme n'a
pas activer qu'à un seul braquage et ce
braquage c'est le fameux braquage de la
rue Joffre de La Poste à Nice
d'après Philippe Rousseau ce jour-là
c'est Michel renard qui faisait le gay
et qui conduisait la voiture
les policiers se rendent immédiatement
chez lui à Nice
mais son arrestation ne va pas se
dérouler comme prévu
lorsqu'ils arrivent au domicile de
Michel renard les policiers sont
accueillis par sa belle-fille Alexandra
Martin qui est aussi la compagne de
Philippe Rosso
quand les policiers arrivent au domicile
de Michel renard dans le but de
l'interpeller Michel renard n'est pas là
donc ils vont faire une perquisition ils
vont fouiller l'appartement
il y a pas de Michel renard mais plus
extraordinaire encore il y a rien il y a
plus ses affaires comme s'il s'était
volatilisé les policiers demandent alors
des explications à la jeune femme et
elle est formelle son beau-père elle ne
l'a pas vu depuis des mois moi mon
beau-père je l'ai plus revu depuis la
mi-novembre 1998 à la mi-novante 98 il a
quitté le domicile et on ne l'a plus
jamais revu la jeune fille en est
certaine c'est même elle qui avait
signalé sa disparition Alexandra Martine
est allé le 15 novembre 98 devant les
services de police en indiquant que son
beau-père avait disparu avait quitté le
domicile la veille et qu'il avait pris
toutes ses affaires et qu'il n'avait
plus réapparu laissant ces deux filles
mineures et Alexandra Martin seul au
domicile
les policiers sont intrigués Michel
Renard a disparu seulement deux semaines
après le braquage de la poste de Nice
les enquêteurs se disent c'est son
premier braquage soit il s'est fait
avoir par ses complices par d'autres
voyous soit il a décidé de se mettre en
cavale et de quitter donc le territoire
les enquêteurs se tournent alors
naturellement vers les compagnons de
braquage de Michel renard
eux sont formelles ils n'ont pas revu
Michel renard depuis la mi-novembre 1998
pour eux voilà c'était son premier
braquage c'était un peu un trouillard et
donc il aurait filt territoire tout
simplement pour se protéger sans aucune
autre piste les enquêteurs sont bien
obligés de croire les braqueurs et c'est
alors que dans leur propre fichier ils
vont faire une nouvelle découverte
[Musique]
le jour où Alexandra Martin a déclaré la
disparition de son beau-père au
commissariat elle ne sait pas arrêter là
dans la foulée de cette disparition elle
dépose plein de combustion
c'était un élément peu banal dit tiens
mon papa a quitté le foyer familial nous
laisse nous abandonne moi et mes deux
soeurs mais dans la foulée je dépose
plein de contre cet homme terrible qui
prodigué ils a touchements sexuels sur
moi et précisera également à ce
moment-là sur ces deux demi-sœurs mais
alors pourquoi attendre la disparition
de Michel renard pour dénoncer ses viols
pour l'heure impossible de répondre
renard est donc toujours introuvable et
cela n'inquiète personne
à tel point que la justice va classer
l'affaire en 2000 et du coup on
abandonne les poursuites et les
recherches concernant Michel renard
quand t'as Philippe Rousseau élu confré
ils sont incarcérés en attendant leur
procès pour volaille
[Musique]
février 2001 cela fait deux ans que
Philippe Rousseau étant détention
provisoire à Grasse l'homme est convoqué
par un juge parisien pour régler son
divorce
un déplacement qui nécessite que
Philippe Rosso sorte de prison pour un
transport en avion depuis Nice
on est sur le tarmac de l'aéroport les
policiers enfin les ceux qui s'occupent
de cette surveillance voilà sont un
petit peu distraits il profite de de la
discussion des services de police des
policiers qui l'accompagnent avec les
hôtesses puisque le voyage se fait en
avion pour sauter sur le tarmac et il
s'évade
[Musique]
à ce moment là ça va très vite dans sa
tête il se dit il faut que j'échappe il
faut que j'échappe à tout ça
on peut aussi se demander s'il y a pas
autre chose que c'est hold-up qui lui
ont donné envie de partir voyez quelque
chose de plus grave Philippe Rosso
aurait-il autre chose à se reprocher
avec son évasion il devient l'un des
hommes les plus recherchés de la Côte
d'Azur
il en planque il est aux abois Philippe
Rousseau et là il va faire ce qui s'est
fait c'est à dire des braquages
il a commettre une dizaine de voile
des braquages qui vont même finir par le
faire tomber après trois mois de cavale
l'homme est à nouveau arrêté en flagrant
délit bientôt il devra répondre de ses
actes devant une cour d'assise un procès
qui pourrait bien faire basculer une
banane à faire deux braquage en une
affaire criminelle hors du commun
14 mars 2002 c'est le procès du gang des
braqueurs de Nice
Rosso et on frais sont jugés pour une
trentaine de braquage mais dans le box
des accusés il manque pourtant quelqu'un
à ce procès c'est vrai que il y a deux
choses qui ressortent c'est Philippe
Rosso l'instigateur celui qui était le
braquage et l'absence de Michel renard
on n'en sait pas plus qu'est-ce qu'il
est devenu on sait pas
à l'issue du procès lui confrère
condamné à 11 années de réclusion
Philippe Rosso à 32 ans
Michel renard jugé par contumace et
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour sa
participation au braquage de la poste de
Nice
il est officiellement enfui
mais c'est l'actualité quelques mois
plus tard qui va relancer l'enquête sur
sa disparition
[Musique]
à criminalité nouvelle réponse
judiciaire nouvelle la France va créer
un statut de repenti réduction de peine
et protection en échange d'une
collaboration avec la justice
ce projet de loi sur les repentis va
finir par donner des idées à Philippe
Rosso qui est incarcéré lui depuis près
de 5 ans
monsieur Rousseau peut demander des
remises de peine
pour ça il faut qu'il avoue des faits
pour ça il faut qu'il rentre dans le
cadre du repentis
pour ça il faut qu'ils disent à la
justice
regardez je vous ai apporté des faits
grâce à moi vous pouvez les juger
libérez moi
il écrit une lettre au procureur de la
République dans laquelle il va faire des
révélations fracassantes
détaillé expliquant comment Michel Rona
a été assassiné à son domicile par une
personne qui le boucher qui n'est autre
que du confront frais surnommé le
boucher aurait donc tué Michel renard
l'information est à peine croyable
[Musique]
les gendarmes de la brigade de recherche
de Nice vont immédiatement entendre
Philippe Rosso en prison
face à eux l'homme commence à raconter
[Musique]
tout aurait commencé en 1998 par une
discussion qu'il aurait tué avec
Alexandra sa petite amie de l'époque
Alexandra Martin va lui faire des
confidences sur son beau-père elle va
lui dire qu'elle a été victime de
violence
d'agressions sexuelles et que ces
petites sœurs également ont été victimes
[Musique]
elle parle très rapidement de du souhait
de faire disparaître son beau-père elle
le dira je souhaite sa mort je veux le
voir disparaître Philippe Rosso raconte
au gendarmes qu'il aurait refusé
d'exécuter renard et il dit Alexandra
non je n'ai pas l'intention de tuer ou
de trouver quelqu'un pour pour tuer
Michel renard en revanche je vais lui
donner une correction Philippe Rosso
aurait donc décidé de trouver un
complice pour l'aider un certain Luc
Onfray il lui fait part que il a un ami
digne de confiance à qui va en parler
cet ami et son meilleur ami du moment
qui est donc lui confrère et qui va
pouvoir l'aider dans son entreprise pour
mettre une correction donc à Michel Ron
seulement au moment d'infliger cette
correction Philippe Rosso raconte que
les choses ont dégénéré lui confrère
aurait abattu Michel renard
les gendarmes sont méfiants et si
Philippe Rosso avait tout inventé pour
obtenir une remise de peine on se dit
attention est-ce que c'est pas c'est pas
affabulation quelques débilité on peut
accorder à ce garçon-là c'est quand même
un personnage important
niçoise parce que quand même trentaine
de voile à armée c'est pas rien c'est
pas donné à tout le monde dans cette
affaire
pas de preuve matérielles il n'y a pas
de cadavre on a seulement des aveux de
Philippe Rousseau qui viennent six ans
après les faits mais comme il est
d'usage lui confrère est entendu à son
tour
il va toujours être dans cette situation
de défense dire je n'ai rien fait
Philippe Rosso invente absolument tout
je n'y suis pour rien lui confrère ni
tout en blanc alors qui dit vrai
il faudra attendre plus de 4 années pour
découvrir la vérité
février 2008 lui confrère bénéficie
d'une libération conditionnelle ce qui
l'ignore c'est qu'il est observé les
gendarmes ne vont pas le lâcher d'une
semelle leur objectif savoir si Philippe
Rosso a dit vrai nous confront à 42 ans
il vient de sortir de prison donc c'est
le moment pour les enquêteurs de le
surveiller un petit peu et voir si
éventuellement on pourrait pas avoir
d'autres éléments sur sur ces fameuses
révélations de Philippe Rousseau donc
ils vont décider de le suivre et de
regarder un petit peu au niveau de ses
appels téléphoniques de voir l'entourage
de lui confrer les semaines de
surveillance succèdent en vain Luc on
ferait semble avoir repris une vie
rangée et comment ça se réinsérer vous
avez un homme qui se dit voilà j'ai
purgé ma peine j'ai bénéficié d'une
libération conditionnelle
aujourd'hui il faut que je demande à mes
amis à ceux qui m'ont connu de me
trouver un travail et à sa sortie de
prison il se passera un extraordinaire
dans sa vie il est devenu paysagiste il
s'occupe d'espace vert il serait donc
une jeune femme assidûment il va à
l'Opéra on est vraiment très loin de
l'affreux braqueurs des années 90 et
surtout on est loin du criminel décrit
par Philippe Rosso celui qui l'avait
surnommé le boucher les gendarmes sont
gagnées par de sérieux dotes
quand même
il sort il a l'air de d'être assez calme
de vivre une vie tout à fait normale une
occupe un studio chez sa maman est-ce
que finalement
Philippe Rousseau n'a pas extrapolé n'a
pas exagéré dans ses révélations
Philippe Rosso a-t-il tout simplement
menti pour en avoir le cœur net les
gendarmes vont passer l'appartement de
Philippe Rosso scène supposée du crime
au peigne fin à la recherche d'indices
on se dit qu'est-ce qui peut être
intéressant dans un premier temps les
constatations dans l'appartement de
Philippe Rousseau même 10 ans après on
va pas s'en priver
dix ans après l'effet l'ancien
appartement de Philippe Rosso rue Dabray
recèle-t-il encore des traces du meurtre
supposé de Michel renard
[Musique]
l'appartement de Philippe Rosso a été
évidemment relouée depuis des années et
du coup on risque de ne pas trouver
grand chose en revanche il reste un
procédé c'est le luminol qui lui permet
de retrouver des traces de sang même
très anciennes
les experts de la gendarmerie passent
alors l'appartement aux luminol et après
quelques instants le résultat est
stupéfiant il y a bien des projections
et des coulures de sang dans presque
toutes les pièces
[Musique]
il va relever 17 zones positives de
traces de sang humain
notamment
la cuisine la salle de bain et la
chambre vu la quantité de son détectée
les gendarmes sont désormais convaincus
qu'un meurtre particulièrement sanglant
s'est déroulé dans cet appartement en
fait
il s'est passé quelque chose comme la
difficulté
de Michel renard
impossible de répondre
le problème c'est que 10 ans après une
salle de bain c'est d'aller
régulièrement avec des produits quand
même assez agressif
on va se retrouver avec peu de matière
beaucoup de traces mais peu de matière
et il m'attire pas assez riche pas si
riche pourquoi pour tout simplement
extraire un profil ADN
mais à qui appartient donc ce sont
trouvé dans l'appartement les enquêteurs
ne vont pourtant pas tarder à le
découvrir
5 décembre 2008 Philippe Rosso quitte sa
cellule détenu modèle il a obtenu une
permission de sortie de trois mois pour
aller travailler sur un chantier
et comme les gendarmes l'avaient prévu
dès sa sortie l'homme en profite pour
rappeler Alexandra
rien n'est laissé au hasard la jeune
femme a été placée sur écoute
téléphonique
Alexandre Arthez sa petite amie même si
plus de 10 ans sont passés lui il est
resté 99 intellectuellement sa vie
s'arrête là et les surveillances
téléphoniques vont se révéler
particulièrement payante
il va appeler Alexandra à plusieurs
reprises de multiples reprises
Alexandra au départ et très étonné elle
comprend pas ce qu'il veut en fait 10
ans après elle comprend pas ce qu'il
veut elle lui dit mais pourquoi tu me
rappelles qu'est-ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce que tu attends et job c'était
pour rappeler le bon vieux temps
au fil des jours Alexandra Martin et
Philippe Rousseau se montrent de plus en
plus bavard
tu te souviens de 98 c'était inoubliable
on aurait pu en faire un film
oui c'est vrai on aurait pu en faire un
bon bouquin
Annie
on s'aperçoit que c'est une année
déterminante dans leur vie donc une
année où il s'est passé quelque chose
d'important et si ce quelque chose
d'important n'était autre que la mort de
Michel renard
la conversation téléphonique ne laisse
planer aucun doute
le couple parle ensuite d'un boucher
tu te souviens de ce type du boucher
c'était un vrai robot
oui moi il me faisait peur
les gendarmes ils comprennent enfin plus
exactement ils imaginent qu'il peut
s'agir de lui qu'on ferait
si les propos tenus lors de cette
conversation sont vraies Rosso est
complices de l'assassinat de Michel
renard et Alexandra est au courant de
tout
3 février 2009 le juge décide d'entendre
à nouveau Philippe Rosso 4 ans après ses
révélations
face aux magistrats l'homme se dissoulé
il passe à nouveau aux aveugles
Roussos finalement c'est qu'il a des
remords il a passé des années en prison
et qu'il a envie que la vérité éclate
justement pour pour la famille et pour
soulager aussi les petites filles de
Michel renard pour qu'elle sache la
vérité et voici l'incroyable récit que
fait l'homme aux enquêteurs
tout commence lorsque Rosso décide de
venger sa petite amie Alexandra Martin
victime des attouchements de son
beau-père
avec l'aide de son ami Luc Onfray il
veut infliger une correction à Michel
renard première étape trouver un
prétexte pour l'approcher pour attirer
Michel renard c'est pas très compliqué
ils l'ont proposé de faire un braquage
il avait des problèmes d'argent et donc
il a accepté le 14 novembre 1998 il est
5 heures du matin au domicile de Michel
renard
sa belle-fille Alexandra lui prépare un
café au goût particulièrement amer
Alexandra lui a mis des somnifères dans
le café le fameux samedi matin où il
part
[Musique]
c'est pour atténuer la violence de
Michel renard Michel renard c'est pas un
sens et quelqu'un qui a qui armé en
permanence chez lui c'est quelqu'un qui
a participé à un braquage c'est
quelqu'un qui s'anone à la boisson du
matin au soir donc c'est pas non plus un
tendre
après avoir bu son café
Michel renard sort de chez lui
il a rendez-vous avec Luc Onfray
récupère Michel Monard la mène au
domicile de Philippe Rousseau donc au 24
rue d'après
comme prévu Philippe Rosso accueille lui
confrère et Michel renard
les trois hommes s'installent dans le
salon pour parler du braquage
en attendant que les somnifères agissent
Rosso propose une partie d'échec à ce
moment-là Rosso il sent pas encore c'est
pas encore le moment d'agir donc il dit
voilà il temporise un peu c'est ce qui
explique
[Musique]
petit à petit Michel renard va commencer
à s'affaiblir
[Musique]
selon Philippe Rosso c'est à ce
moment-là que lucré aurait brusquement
décidé d'éliminer Michel renard offrez
une correction ça suffit pas une
correction ça suffit pas mais ne
t'inquiète pas moi je vais m'en occuper
sur le coup Philippe Rosso n'y croit pas
et sort comme si de rien n'était acheté
des croissants
mais à son retour vers 6h du matin il
découvre une scène digne d'un film
d'horreur
il revient et là il voit le corps de
Michel renard allongé la tête dans un
sac plastique avec des traces de sang
et là lui comprit
à partir de ce moment là c'est la
panique c'est la panique totale parce
que ce qu'il craignait et c'est qu'il
n'avait osé imaginer c'est passé
[Musique]
toujours selon Philippe Rousseau Luc
Onfray aurait tué Michel renard à coup
de marteau là lui confrère ne t'inquiète
pas je m'occupe de tout laisse moi faire
je vais me débarrasser du corps tu me
laisses tout seul tu me laisses ce
weekend j'en ai pour deux jours je
m'occupe du reste
[Musique]
pétrifié Philippe Rosso aurait alors
quitté son appartement pour rejoindre
Alexandra quand il arrive chez Alexandra
il lui dit
Michel est
morte à la base Philippe Rousseau devait
simplement donner le correction et ça
devait pas aller plus loin
pour détourner les soupçons les deux
amants auraient alors décidé de faire
croire à une disparition volontaire
c'est Alexandra Martin qui va
débarrasser les affaires de Michel
renard des armoires elle va elle
organiser cette disparition pour que ses
sœurs puissent croire en cette
disparition et pour brouiller davantage
les pistes tous les deux décident
d'aller signaler la disparition de
Michel renard au commissariat
Rosso raconte qu'en route ils font un
détour par la rue d'abret pour voir où
en élu qu'on ferait Alexandra elle
attend dans la voiture
avec Alexandra il retourne donc voir lui
confrère il lui amène un sandwich et des
cigarettes lorsqu'il va rentrer
il va s'apercevoir du carnage
et les traces de sang un peu partout il
voit des morceaux de l'ombre de chair
accrochés sur les murs à ce moment-là
lui confrère lui aurait expliqué
l'inimaginable celui-ci va lui dire
voilà j'ai découpé j'ai découpé le corps
etc
le sang qui est inclusive c'est parce
que je passais cher au mixeur
et ensuite c'est cher mixé sont évacués
par les toilettes
quant aux os qui ne passaient pas au
mixeur Luc on ferait les aurait mis dans
des sacs avant de les disperser dans des
poubelles aux quatre coins de la ville
devant le juge médusé Philippe Rousseau
explique qu'en découvrant le carnage il
a totalement paniqué s'est enfui et s'il
n'a pas dénoncé le confrère c'est qu'il
était terrifié à ce moment-là il a eu
peur pour lui-même aussi il s'est dit
ouh là est-ce que le confrère va pas
s'occuper de moi maintenant face à ce
témoignage incroyable les enquêteurs se
posent de nombreuses questions d'après
Philippe Rosso lui confrait et le tueur
et Alexandra l'instigatrice mais lui
quel est son rôle au juste on peut se
demander si Philippe Rosso n'est pas
plus impliqué que ce qu'il veut bien
admettre ou prétendre Philippe Rousseau
dénonce les faits mais semble minimiser
fortement sa participation à ces
derniers une chose est néanmoins
certaine sans les dénonciations de
Philippe Rosso Michel renard serait
toujours un simple disparu
pour en savoir plus les enquêteurs
décident de confronter le confrère et
Alexandra Martin a ses déclarations
[Musique]
4 février 2009 au petit matin le
confrère est interpellé à son domicile
les gendarmes lui indiquent qu'il est
soupçonné d'assassinat et curieusement
l'homme reste de marbre
il est interpellé rien ne le gène rien
ne le choque
et il nous écoute et c'est tout
les gendarmes perquisitionnent son
appartement mais disant après les faits
il ne trouvera rien
reste cependant la cave à fouiller et
c'est là qu'ils vont faire des
découvertes inespérées ils vont trouver
différentes choses qui correspondent à
la description de Philippe Rosso
Ie un couteau
peut-être pour déposer des animaux
des objets qui pourraient bien avoir
servi aux dépeçage mais la liste ne
s'arrête pas là dans un des cartons le
chef d'équipe fait une découverte encore
plus intéressante le chef il couvre un
mixe
exactement ce qui avait écrit Philippe
Rousseau lors de lors de ses
affirmations
au juge
on se dit mais en étant très réservé
parce que
la taille du mixeur
sur le bol du mixeur les gendarmes
remarque une trace brunâtre une trace
qui ressemble à du sang séché peut-être
celui de Michel renard
tous les scellés sont envoyés pour être
analysés en attendant les résultats les
gendarmes entendent le confrère
son interrogatoire commence les
gendarmes décident d'aller droit au but
a-t-il oui ou non tu es puis découper
Michel renard le 14 novembre 1998
l'homme ni en bloc monsieur on ferait
n'a qu'une version au travers de
l'enquête c'est monsieur Rousseau délir
il a vu trop de films vous me parlez
d'un scénario de films gore vous avez vu
trop de films d'horreur
c'est une vengeance etc
on freine n'aurait donc rien fait pour
lui le seul responsable c'est Philippe
Rosso et pour cause il haïssait Michel
renard et pas seulement à cause des
agressions commises sur Alexandra
lorsque les braquages sont commis avec
monsieur Renard monsieur Renard qui
n'est pas un professionnel lui ne va
avoir d'autres réflexes que de se vanter
dans des soirées avoir commis des
braquages il va dire Philippe Rosso
voulait faire disparaître Michel renard
parce que Michel renard était devenu
bavard quant au mixeur découvert dans sa
cave lui confrère accuse à nouveau
Philippe Rosso si ce mixeur est à son
domicile
c'est parce qu'il a été effectivement
prêté à Monsieur Rosso ce qu'il se fait
entre amis les dossiers prouvent qui se
fréquentent régulièrement et ensuite
rendu par monsieur Rousseau monsieur
Aufray le récupérant le mettant dans sa
cave sans se douter qu'il y a une trace
de sang une explication peu crédible aux
yeux des enquêteurs toujours est-il
qu'il leur faut déterminer le vrai du
faux et pour cela il compte bien sûr
Alexandra
[Musique]
dans un bureau voisin Alexandra Martin
est interrogé
et même 10 ans après la jeune femme
comprend très vite les raisons de sa
présence
[Musique]
elle craque immédiatement devant les
enquêteurs elle est soulagée donc elle
pleure elle dit ah je suis ça me fait du
bien à la limite d'être là je vais
pouvoir tout dire immédiatement
expliquer que quand son beau-père est
parti elle savait pourquoi il partait
surtout elle savait qu'il reviendrait
pas et Alexandra Martin donne sa version
une version qui ne va pas du tout aller
dans le sens de Philippe Rosso oui elle
lui a parlé des attouchements sexuels
dont elle était victime mais selon elle
il n'a jamais été question de correction
c'est lors d'une discussion ensemble ou
Philippe Rosso va lui dire est-ce que tu
veux qu'il meurt elle répond oui
pas moi qui dit qu'il fallait le tuer
mais comme lui il me le propose je
profite cette occasion je saute dessus
et je dis oui la jeune femme est
formelle il s'agissait bien de tuer
Michel renard elle savait même que
Philippe Rousseau allait le faire avec
l'aide d'un autre homme elle lâche alors
un mot loin d'être anodin là il va
parler d'un boucher de d'un boucher qui
aurait été utilisé pour faire
disparaître le corps mais se boucher
Alexandra Martin dit ignorait son
identité à ce stade difficile pour les
enquêteurs de se prononcer sur le rôle
exact de chacun en Yann on a ça cette
fois-ci on sait qu'il est mort on sait
qu'il y a deux acteurs sur Philippe
Rousseau
Alexandre Martin ça c'est avéré par leur
déclaration maintenant et la
triangulaire se fait parce que on a
ressentircuse
Alessandra Martin qui avoue sans avouer
et on ferait qu'il y a des objets
compromettant chez lui voilà la donne
à l'issue de ces gardes à vue lui
confrère est mis en examen pour
assassinat
Alexandra Martin et Philippe Rosso ne
sont accusés que de complicité du moins
pour l'instant
dans le cadre de leur enquête de
personnalité de luconfrais les gendarmes
entendent un certain Michael un ancien
ami qui a travaillé avec lui et lors de
son audition le jeune homme va raconter
l'incroyable proposition que lui aurait
fait mon frère
monsieur Auffret je confirme est venu
chez moi et à tenté de me débaucher pour
faire disparaître trois corps en
m'expliquant comment faire il faut les
couper en morceaux mixer les chairs
faire disparaître les eaux les gendarmes
sont stupéfaits car évidemment le
procédé leur rappelle quelque chose
mais si vous regardez bien comment il
décrit comment va se débarrasser des
corps si on n'est plus ni moins que la
façon qui a donné fini prosault pour se
débarrasser du corps
ça fait maintenant trois personnes
Martine Rosso et ce fameux Michael qui
implique lui confrère en parlant d'un
mixeur qui implique lui confrères avec
des cadavres des corps découpés
pour les enquêteurs le témoignage de
Michael est capital et leur conviction
va être renforcée par un nouvel élément
accablant
les résultats des analyses effectuées
sur le mixeur retrouvé dans la cave de
luconfrais viennent de tomber
ces traces brunâtres ont été analysées
il s'agit du sang de Michel renard
c'est un formidable coup d'accélérateur
à l'enquête parce que je vous rappelle
que le mixeur a été retrouvé dans la
cave de lui confrères même si ce dernier
prétend qu'il a prêté à Philippe
Rousseau
c'est la première fois qu'on a un
élément incontournable dans cette
affaire
le juge convoque à nouveau le confrère
en apprenant les résultats des analyses
ADN l'homme confirme sa première version
ce mixeur en fait je l'ai prêté à
Philippe Rosso et d'ailleurs il me
l'avait rendu la veille ou l'avant
veille de notre arrestation en février
99 tout d'un coup la mémoire lui revient
il n'avait jamais parlé de cette date-là
très régulier
c'est ce moment où avoir une mémoire
d'éléphant lui confrère est-il l'unique
auteur de l'assassinat de Michel renard
Philippe Rosso est-il un simple complice
et Alexandra est-elle l'instigatrice de
la mort de son beau-père
c'est désormais le procès qui devra
apporter les réponses à ces questions
un procès qui va s'ouvrir par un
incroyable coup de théâtre
16 janvier 2012 cours d'assise de Nice
plus de 13 ans après les faits le procès
des assassins de Michel renard peut
enfin commencer sur le banc des accusés
Alexandra Martin et Philippe Rousseau
comparaissent libres pour complicité
d'assassinat
quant à lui confesse celui que la presse
surnomme le tueur au mixeur il se tient
derrière la vitre du box des accusés les
filles de Michel renard sont présentes
elles sont bouleversées mes clientes
sont en pleurs
parce que pour la première fois depuis
10 ans
elles espèrent que elles vont
apprendre
la vérité dans la salle avant même
l'ouverture de l'audience tous les
regards se tournent vers la table des
pièces à conviction et au milieu des
scellés se trouvent le fameux mixeur
ayant servi à faire disparaître le corps
de Michel renard quand le mixeur était
posé sur la table tout le monde a eu un
mouvement de recul c'est étonnant même
certains jurés on les a vu un petit peu
reculer sur la chaise ça c'est ça c'est
assez impressionnant avant d'aborder les
faits la présidente donne la parole aux
accusés
Alexandra Martin et Philippe Rousseau
décline leur identité quand on vient le
tour de Luc on ferait l'homme se lève et
fait d'incroyable révélations
vu qu'on ferait dans le box des accusés
il se tient voilà sur les vitres du box
et là avec son micro face à la
Présidente il avoue c'est bien moi qui
ai fait disparaître le corps
c'est bien moi qui
les découpé c'est bien moi qui l'ai
dépecé
silence dans la salle
les personnes témoins de cette audience
comme les intervenants sont stupéfaites
après 13 ans de silence Luc confré a
décidé de tout révéler l'homme décrit
même point par point le découpage du
corps de Michel renard les mots sont
crus
voilà il y a un certain dégoût
finalement qui ressort de cette
description morbide et d'autant plus que
lui reste totalement impassible il va
aller très très loin dans les détails il
va expliquer que il découpait au cutter
ou à la scie des morceaux des os des
tendons c'était assez glaçant quant au
mix lui confrère qu'il s'en est à peine
servi il va indiquer que le mixeur oui
il était là oui il a tenté de broyer
certaines chair avec mais que ça n'a pas
fonctionné et que le corps a bien été
dépecé mais qu'ensuite
le corps a été placé dans des sacs et
ensuite jeter dans des poubelles après
avoir décrit et assumer l'impensable lui
confrère décide qu'il ne tombera pas
seul selon lui se meurtre il ne l'a
jamais souhaité ni même programmé le
responsable c'est Philippe Rosso il va
pas laisser Philippe Rousseau s'en
sortir donc il va accuser Philippe
Rousseau et il va accuser Philippe au
son indiquant Philippe Rosso était là
Philippe Rosso a étranglé Michel renard
il va dire voilà
Philippe Russo venait de l'étrangler
et une fois par terre il m'a dit il m'a
dit de lui donner un dernier coup de
marteau pour voir si il était bien mort
tous les yeux se tournent alors vers
Philippe Rosso
appelé à la barre l'homme jure qu'il n'a
pas tué Michel renard mais personne ne
semble y croire mon seul tort c'est de
pas voir un pur empêcher le crime mon
seul tort c'est ne pas mettre douter que
ça tournerait mal mon seul tort c'est
d'avoir voulu une correction mon seul
tort c'est de ne pas avoir de dénoncer
l'effet plutôt Philippe Rosso a bien du
mal à justifier sa version de la
correction qui a mal tourné
la motivation de ce rendez-vous qui est
de dire c'était pour lui infliger une
correction non non ça c'est pas possible
c'était pas pour lui infliger une
correction que le principe une
correction c'est que celui qui corrigé
sache pourquoi il l'est et on ressentent
les effets
le fait de verser un médicament qui a
justement vocation à atténuer les
réactions voire même à endormir
là ça ne va pas non plus au fil des
débats le procès se retourne
complètement contre Philippe Rosso même
le mobile du meurtre semble avoir évolué
il n'aurait pas seulement comme origine
les agressions sexuelles commises sur
Alexandra le mobile du crime n'est pas
du tout celui que veut bien nous vendre
Philippe Rousseau et que ce n'est autre
qu'un mobile crapuleux monsieur Rousseau
a été furieux contre monsieur Renard qui
se vante en soirée vous avez un chef de
gang qui voit un de ces lieutenant
nouveau intronisé aller dans les soirées
et dire regarder c'est moi sur le
journal c'est moi qui ai fait ces
braquages dans son réquis oire l'avocat
général présente Philippe Rousseau comme
le cerveau de l'assassinat de Michel
renard un Michel renard devenu trop
bavard trop dangereux pour la vie du
gang le confrère quant à lui n'a été que
l'exécutant dévoué et méthodique de
Philippe Rousseau Alexandra Martin
agressé sexuellement à juste servi de
caution morale
après quatre jours de débat les jurides
doivent trancher
[Musique]
jeudi 19 janvier 2012 c'est l'heure du
verdict
[Musique]
Philippe Rosso est condamné à 28 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour avoir
commandité et organiser la mort de
Michel renard
ou cette peine injuste
parce qu'il est sorti de prison il y a
pas longtemps donc il retournait c'est
difficile pour lui et surtout parce que
voilà il a une attitude
quoi qu'on ait pu en dire il a une
attitude de repentir et d'une véritable
prise de conscience et aujourd'hui cette
prise de conscience et se repentir n'est
absolument pas on n'a pas tenu compte
devant la Cour d'Assise Luc Onfray lui
est condamné à 30 ans de prison pour
l'assassinat de Michel renard Alexandra
Martine bénéficie quant à elle de la
clémence de la cour 5 années avec sursis
c'est la réalité c'est-à-dire que elle
est peut-être complice d'assassinat mais
en même temps elle a toujours été
omniprésente pour ses soeurs et ce qui
s'est passé elle l'a fait pour elle mais
aussi pour ses sœurs pour les protéger
il faut pas l'oublier
ironie du sort les aveux de Philippe
Rosso se sont finalement retournés
contre lui sans ces révélations la mort
de Michel renard n'aurait jamais été
élucidé
[Musique]